[Música]
vamos a las noticias de salud con Mara
Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela un nuevo estudio nos
habla de lo dañina que puede ser la
industria de la leche de fórmula en la
salud de niños y madres nos sorprende
Pues no tanto de hecho la Organización
Mundial de la Salud ya lleva tiempo
advirtiendo en contra de esta industria
y este nuevo estudio publicado con the
lanced tiene unas conclusiones
contundentes escuchemos
durante décadas la industria de leche de
fórmula ha usado estrategias comerciales
subrepticias diseñadas para aprovecharse
de los miedos y las preocupaciones de
los padres y madres en un momento
vulnerable para convertir la
alimentación infantil en un negocio de
millones de dólares la recomendación de
la OMS siempre es que Durante los
primeros seis meses de vida de un bebé
la lactancia materna sea exclusiva algo
que solo sigue más o menos la
recomendación la mitad de los niños que
existen actualmente un poco menos de
hecho y tiene muchos beneficios para la
salud para decir solo algunos un sistema
inmune más fuerte ya que la leche
materna puede dar anticuerpos también
ayuda a la microbiota intestinal que
también influye en el sistema inmune
además en el digestivo se sabe que a
largo plazo hace que los niños que luego
sean adultos tengan menos enfermedades
crónicas y también sobre la misma salud
de la madre se sabe que las madres que
han dado pecho que han dado de mamar
tienen menos incidencia por ejemplo en
cáncer de seno o en cáncer de ovarios
bien qué argumentos entonces utiliza la
industria de la leche de fórmula para
venderse como algo positivo pues es muy
controvertido no porque van en contra de
las propias recomendaciones de la salud
internacionales y en general digamos que
el uso del marketing se hace para que se
muestren como un remedio a ciertos
problemas Estos son algunas
reproducciones no son exactas las hizo
de lanced para no entrar en conflictos
digamos con algunas de las marcas pero
vemos que muestran por ejemplo que sea
suave para una digestión que calma a los
niños que los va a ayudar a dormir cosas
que son bastante normales en el
desarrollo de un bebé Que tengan un
sueño interrumpido por ejemplo y que en
caso de que no sean normales quizás la
solución no es esta la fórmula de leche
sino en visitar por ejemplo a un médico
que ayude pues a buscar otro tipo de
soluciones digamos que se juega con los
miedos las incomodidades o las dudas de
padres y madres para vender hay otros
ejemplos que se muestran a veces como
suplementos que van a ayudar a
desarrollar el cerebro la capacidad
intelectual de los niños algo que no
está apoyado en ningún tipo de evidencia
científica que no es cierto y que más
bien lleva a subestimar El Poder y los
beneficios alcanza materna y ahondar
esas inseguridades no pensar que no es
suficiente lo que una madre o un padre
una persona lactante puede estar
haciendo Mire no hay nada más
evolucionado y más tecnológico que la
leche materna dicho eso madre por
supuesto que la lactancia es una
decisión únicamente que corresponde a la
madre no por supuesto sin entrar a
ningún tipo de juicio sino simplemente
entendiendo pues Cuáles son los
beneficios y las contraindicaciones de
hecho el estudio de la OMS y delante
pone cifra un poco a estas
contraindicaciones o estos efectos de
las sobre la salud que puede tener no
lactar exclusivamente y calculan por
ejemplo que los ingresos de la industria
de Fórmula rondan los 55.000 millones de
euros anuales de los cuales se destinan
3.000 millones en mercadeo y publicidad
pero las pérdidas causadas a largo plazo
por la salud Son seis veces más grandes
350.000 millones de dólares anuales se
pierden digamos a largo plazo a raíz de
la salud de no estar lactando
exclusivamente en los primeros seis
meses de edad Como decías No es tan
fácil además que es que no se tiene que
dar fórmula no que simplemente se tiene
que lactar eso no es fácil porque el
sistema además en general no ayuda que
las madres pues lacten den pecho Durante
los primeros seis meses de vida del niño
y socialmente se pedía también no Uno
que se valore eso como también un
trabajo que tiene un coste económico y
que se redistribuya no que se ayude que
sea invierta en estas tareas de Cuidado
de las madres es que sacarse leche no es
fácil mar pero sabe que para el cierre
un argumento que usan mucho en los
hospitales es que los niños quedan con
hambre claro eso no es cierto en el
tamaño del estómago de un bebé No la
verdad es que no una no es así de grande
ahí tenemos la respuesta gracias Ángela